for women to shame men for their
standards like if men don't women above
35 so what yeah I don't know it's not
it's not shiny it's like if I don't want
a woman to be fed am I fat shaming like
I don't understand this it's like women
can say they want men who are six foot
and they want a washboard abs and all
this and you don't see men on the
streets crying that they that they're
being you know where's the the short
short man positivity exactly
I think that's I think that's easy from
like a woman's point of view
um because a lot of times like we don't
notice it but it's like every time a man
has standards there's always a woman
shaming him for having them so like for
example when a guy says I don't like I
don't like fat chicks like then all of a
sudden he's fat phobic if he says if he
says I don't I don't like [ __ ] then
like they have then they have the [ __ ]
walk if he says that I don't like
um yeah but like every every time that a
man has standards he's shamed for it I
don't but I don't think that's a quote
unquote a standard I think that's like
that like the way the way I'm
interpreting what you just said is and
maybe it may not be in the way that you
that you mean but when someone's saying
I don't like fat chicks like that to me
is fetching me
I don't like to date fat chicks but I
can say on air I don't like to date
short men I'm six foot if a guy's
significantly shorter than me I'm just
not gonna go for it but as I said we're
allowed to have preferences women are
but men are men are but they think the
different no no this is the problem and
I'll tell you what the problem is social
media has given people a voice a echo
chamber remember if there was no socials
you wouldn't really be hearing about it
you'd have to accept your fate as a man
and live and walk through it without
this Echo chamber like the podcast right
now because there's been a nature that's
I don't know being bestowed upon us with
technology we're constantly hearing men
have to have this men have to have that
and the reality is they'd actually they
don't they don't actually have to have
it yeah because the reason why they
don't have to have it is because if
they're the provider in the relationship
they have the power to to execute the
woman out of their relationship if they
want to if they're willing to lose half
of their property
do you think it's really that easy to be
a man and be able to provide yeah so
John I'm sorry yeah take this in right
yeah once again I'm a five foot six man
give or take half an inch right majority
of my life women have told me to my face
yo hey you know what I find you
attractive your Vibe is cool but you
know what just a little bit too short
you feel me that me as a man I can't cry
about it you feel me yeah it's called an
acceptance
you know what I've actually been
learning recently is that you can
survive off of one income in places like
the UK and then the US I talked to
someone that raised 10 foster kids off
of ten thousand dollars per year and she
still maintains that income but the
problem is women um spend frivolously
and they don't want that to go down in
lifestyle for a family typically
you move outside of the country and the
guy run like goes to the city yeah well
I just wanted to say to you because you
know I understand your pain what you're
talking about your experience right but
you're living proof you have a partner
that respects you you have a higher
quality partner than a lot of these six
foot plus guys yes or no yes or no no
but here's the thing I have been
extremely lucky and he's watching this
shout out to you baby here's the thing
you're saying this look it's not luck
because you're the man and you've
persevered
in your life I think that's I think
that's easy to say like what modern
women have ridiculous standards yeah
yeah women women always want an above
average man even if they're average
I understand but this young this guy
here young man yeah this gentleman here
he's he's he's told us he's below
average height he told us that he was
willing to go and learn boxing he's told
us he's got a woman that is better than
a lot of the women that maybe come on
this podcast maybe better than me I
don't know her but she may be she's
better than these average women that
we're talking about the Modern Woman
she's better than the mother woman yes
or no but I just understand she is but
understand
at that there's a probability versus
possibility yeah and that one percent of
men who managed to somehow find one girl
no no no no but but as a man why are you
watching other what other men are doing
you I don't care
would you fulfilled your position he's
got a different goal yeah he's got a
different goal he's you've got a partner
no
um yeah are you happy with your partner
which is fine but if they get married
the women still leave 70 to 80 percent
of the time 90 of their college educated
so so wait wait wait don't cut me don't
cut me off if women still leave 70 to 80
of the time 90 of their college educated
so he could he could get that
traditional girl but that doesn't mean
she won't leave him later yeah but
that's that's her probability that's a
risk that's it yeah that's a problem so
it's luck
but like I think that's just not like I
just try to empathize with men because
if I if I as a woman was going into
marriage knowing that I was going to be
left 70 to 80 percent of the time 90 if
I get a college educated guy [ __ ] I
probably would say [ __ ] marriage too
women I'm living in mass
please understand this why I'm in a very
unique situation my girl was Muslim yeah
you get it so she's got a different that
type of mindset when it comes to life in
it majority of mandum and the reason I'm
speaking on this podcast right now is
for the majority of mandum I'm lucky I'm
good but majority of man them are not
and how many girls did you have to go
through till you got oh don't even get
me Style
so how many how many bad bad girls did
you have to date before you found the
one oh my listen this is this is
okay okay
in the mid-20s range yeah it's someone
found one girl who was literally
traditional and to the point where I can
be like you know what I can take you
serious you feel me yeah so how old are
you sorry I'm 27 years old you're 27 you
went through 15 girls to find the girl
that you require right so so so you are
you are from what you've said you are
the Pinnacle you are the Pinnacle you're
sure yeah you did boxing you built your
masculinity in a way you got the girl
that you desire you got the girl that
you need for now no no but for now for
now God only knows
I don't think you understand like like
because men never know if a girl is just
gonna up and leave and I I just don't
like I don't think I think to dismiss it
I mean kind of like you're in a you're
in a happy relationship now it's like
even even if it goes to the distance and
he gets married like 70 to 80 chance
she's yeah is that how you live your
life do you live your life like that
you've got a living reality the reality
is you're in a relationship you like
your relationship you love your
relationship you're willing to work on
your relationship you have a good woman
so you don't look at your relationship
and say oh it might fail so I'm gonna
just stop please
because like I said at the start of the
relationship sorry at the start of the
podcast I said yo man's got free YouTube
channels I'm working very hard yeah to
get myself into a position where I can
make enough money to have a good family
and all that kind of [ __ ] but sorry but
at the end of the day
like I'm taking a risk here you feel me
that's life life is a risk you walk
outside you might get hit by a boxes
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay but but it's easy to
say that it's it's very easy to say that
as a woman oh life's risk or whatever
yeah but you're not the one that could
potentially sign up to lose in the UK
it's up to 70 of your [ __ ] you could
work for 20 30 Years be 50 years old she
takes 70 of your [ __ ] I agree but you
then then you follow it and say well
life is about risk you can't just be
afraid I'm like well if you if I was at
a 50 chance that she can leave me and
take the kids yeah and and a lot of guys
have taken the risk and they've read the
brunt of that but at this point what
you're saying is okay get into new
relationships don't try that's not what
he's that's not what he's saying this is
what this is as a generalist statement
yeah we know there's risk I'm aware of
the risk I can see it's unfair for men
but as a man as a woman you must put in
effort if you're not putting in effort
if you see your part no no no wait wait
I know you're getting angry but the
reality I'm not angry about you you know
I'm I'm saying things that people might
say is contradictory I'm not a man I
don't have to live in your shoes I only
observe it and I've as I said many times
on this show I've had the benefits of
what men bring to my table and nobody
else can bring them to my table here's
the thing I want to ask a quick question
yeah it's like okay imagine you are a
man and really really and truly
imagining yourself because you're a
woman right and like you know all
respect to that you're an attractive
woman right so it your entire life
you've probably lived your life man them
come up to me it's like hey what are you
saying girl did you get it like you've
lived that life now imagine you are a
man right and let's say you are at a
disadvantage let's say you are five foot
two and you're fat you feel me you're
not gonna get no attention from yours so
you're gonna have to put in all that
work to become someone yeah that is even
worthy of attention not a relationship
not bedroom fun yeah attention yeah and
that should get it I mean there is there
is a girl there is a girl that pretended
to be a man like she was like a feminist
and she she dressed up like she
basically dressed up as a man for like
three years and she killed herself
because she couldn't believe how people
treat man well she actually got
euthanasia but yeah yeah but she went
and got euthanasia that's different she
didn't jump I mean come on man
as many
as much just
Big Talk we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible